rough night is written and directed by
Liu Jia and yellow one of the writers of
broad city a very successful comedy TV
show that's gotten really good reviews
from people and critics and it's
co-written by Paul W down to also stars
in the film and it's about a
bachelorette party gone very wrong
Scarlett Johansson gillian bells zoe
kravitz and alana grazer are just trying
to have a nice night to themselves and
they hire a male stripper and things go
really wrong with the male stripper in
fact they kind of kill him that's not a
spoiler it's in all the trailers and so
the rest of the film is them trying to
figure out what to do with this body do
they turn themselves in do they hide the
body can they escape Demi Moore and Ty
Burrell the sex-crazed couple that lives
next door these are things that plague
these characters and when I saw the
trailer for this movie I really had no
anticipation for it the trailer just
makes this film look like it's a party
movie from beginning to end it's nothing
but cocaine booze screaming and loud
techno music and the trailer genuinely
annoyed me I had no interest in seeing
it whatsoever but I went anyway and I
got to say come in really close come
here just come here it's okay come over
a little bit closer this movie actually
ain't that bad
I walked out of this theater pleasantly
surprised because the film really isn't
too much like the trailers the first 25
minutes of this movie is like the
trailers they get really high they do
some drugs and they're having fun and as
soon as that happens with the male
stripper they accidentally killed a guy
the movie changes the movie goes from
that frat boy style or in this case frat
girl style humor into something far
darker and the comedy also gets a lot
better and it really improved but the
thing that I genuinely liked about this
movie is the sisterly bond that's felt
between these characters they've been
friends forever and you can really feel
that the movie isn't just about the
situational comedy of what do you do
with a dead body when you're on your
Bachelorette weekend the real heart of
the movie lies in these girls
reconnecting because they've all moved
on with their lives they all have
different careers some of them are kind
of stuck in one place and our little
directionless and they're looking for
that and their friends they're trying to
reconnect and
find that direction again and seeing
them and their sisterly bond grow as the
film proceeded was easily my favorite
part about it it's also surprisingly
funny
I laughed consistently one of the
funnier aspects of this movie is
Scarlett Johansson's fiance which is
played by the co-writer Paul W downs he
stuck back at home and he thinks
something is wrong and so he decides
he's going to go drive there and his
mission to try to get there whenever
they cut back to him I kept thinking I
don't want to see this scene
oh my god that was fucking hilarious ok
now I know I do let's see what else he
has to do it just cut increasingly more
embarrassing and the situational humor
is really strong here for whatever
reason one of my biggest laughs in this
movie is when he's trying to call his
fiancee and leave a message and he makes
this weird space with his upper lip and
sticks out his teeth and it was just so
fucking hilarious I don't know why it
really got me Julianne Bell's character
is very overbearing and at first you're
like okay so she's just that jealous
character who's going to be very jealous
because kate MacKinnon's character is
coming in from australia and is also
friends with Scarlett Johansson and so
Gillian Belle's like hey no no that's my
swagger or you can't do that to me like
that's my girl and then you're you're on
my turf right now bitch you know what I
mean like it's that type of thing and at
first it got really old but as the film
progresses you realize that it's
actually really important to her
character because there's a lot more
depth hidden behind why she is so
overbearing and so it's not just that
she's that character the jealous friend
character who's very annoying it
actually plays into the depth of the
movie and it brought the film around to
a much more dramatic perspective towards
the third act and on yellow is wise to
focus on those friends and their past
and what made them feel like sisters
even though they're not related and not
always have it be about dick jokes
there's a lot of dick jokes there's a
lot of penises in this movie it's
whatever penises who knows I see a penis
every day it's fine I'm used to it all
the girls have really excellent common
timing and work well with one another
they have very good chemistry and kate
mckinnon in this movie finally has a
chance to be really funny but not over
the top because ghostbusters
that didn't work out for me she just it
didn't work out for me I think she's
brilliant I think she's really funny
when it boils down to it I don't go to a
film like this and expect greatness I
just expect a fun and entertaining movie
that will make me laugh if you're having
a girls night out you're probably going
to really enjoy yourself or if you're a
guy like me who doesn't look at films
like this and thinks well those are just
for girls you might enjoy it too that
being said it's unfortunate how similar
this film is to others it's very much so
like very bad things which is about a
group of guys who accidentally kill a
prostitute and then have to try to
figure out how to cover it up it's a
little bit of weekend at Bernie's as
well we've seen films like this before
it's got some hangover and bridesmaids
in there as well it's sort of like a
mishmash of different films the thing
that kept me enjoying it is that
sisterly bond that is ever-present
throughout the movie and realized well
throughout the performances and the
writing I'm going to give rough night of
be trust me I'm surprised I saw the
trailers and my wife and I looked at
each other and we were like yeah that's
that's not for us but I went to the
screening anyway and I'm glad I did
because the tray was basically surmised
the first 25 minutes of the movie and a
lot of the stuff after that is just
little bits in the trailers there's tons
of stuff they don't really show which
was also a major plus there's a lot of
good jokes in the movie that simply
aren't in the trailers so check it out
sometime guys also big thank you to my
buddy Bennett the sage who included me
in his review of kite the American
adaptation of the anime I had a blast
doing that with him please go check out
his channel that link is in the
description below you will see that he
works very hard on his videos and
dedicates quite a bit of time to them
it's pretty good content so thank you
very much Bennet that was a blast to
take part in you guys are the best if
you liked this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Music]
ah